this video originally aired as part of
teching one-on-ones charity stream to
benefit the Children's Tumor Foundation
please check the link in the description
to learn more and be sure to show
teching 101 son love he is genuinely one
of the coolest and nicest people on
YouTube
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the one thing that
we can learn from almost all shown and
protagonists and this one thing is an
absolutely essential lesson to not only
learn but also apply in our own daily
lives shown an anime and manga may be
primarily geared towards a male teenager
audience but this particular lesson
never gets old it's not gender specific
and it is as useful for a teenager as it
is for an octogenarian we've all noticed
it before even if we haven't actually
given it much thought and in many ways
this has become a cliche with Shonen
protagonists but the fact is that almost
every shown in MC has a clear
overarching goal or purpose Luffy wants
to become the Pirate King Ashe wants to
become a Pokemon master
Naruto wants to become the Hokage ah
stuff from black clover wants to become
the wizard King Dec who wants to become
the greatest hero
Goku wants to get stronger and keep
fighting stronger opponents and so on in
sports anime the protagonist usually
wants to be the best he can be or for
his team to do as well as possible and
the MC and food Wars wants to become the
sexiest chef or whatever I still have to
watch that one so I'm just assuming here
sometimes the protagonists overall goal
isn't necessarily an affirmative one for
instance Eren from attack on Titan wants
to kill all the Titans and write the
horrible injustice that he had to endure
as a child when he lost his home and his
mother to the Titans now I know that
there are people out there who can't
really relate to Eren but as someone who
lived through the Yugoslav civil wars as
a child and was a refugee during the war
I understand how Aaron feels thankfully
I didn't lose any members of my
immediate family during the war but my
family did lose everything we owned
including our home and we had to flee
and start over from scratch other
protagonists like Mellie Otis from the
seven deadly sins have an overarching
goal that isn't revealed until later and
I won't mention what it is right now so
as to avoid spoilers but the fact is
that the vast majority of Shonen
protagonists have some sort of clear
goal some purpose that drives their act
even though in most stories the journey
is what really matters not necessarily
the destination so for example even if
Luffy never actually becomes the Pirate
King fans of one piece will still love
the series but the MCS goal does matter
because it drives his actions and
informs his decisions
if Luffy's goal was to be a small town
fisherman or if deck whose goal was to
be an accountant the stories of one
piece and boku no hero would be very
different so we know that the purpose of
a shounen protagonists matters for the
story but what exactly does that have to
do with the real world as cliche as it
sounds to want to be the best of this or
the greatest that it is actually
extremely important for human beings to
have a clear purpose to their lives from
the philosophers of ancient Greece like
Plato and Aristotle and Romans like epic
titus and marcus aurelius to modern day
thinkers and gurus of self-development
like Dale Carnegie and Tony Robbins wise
people have been saying the same thing
for thousands of years humans need to
have a purpose in their lives in order
to feel happy and fulfilled positive
goals and a clear purpose gives our
lives meaning it inspires and motivates
us to work harder and reach greater
heights Heights that we could never have
even imagined if we didn't have a goal
that drives us since you and me are not
anime protagonists we don't have to be
the next master wizard pirate king of
heroes but we do all need a positive
goal a passion and a purpose that drives
us and inspires us this could be
something as simple as providing for
your family or helping others by
volunteering or working as a nurse or it
could be something ambitious like
becoming the president ending world
hunger by inventing a new way to farm
food or finding the cure for terrible
diseases in the modern age many people
have lost sight of how important it is
to have a purpose and many of us drift
through life without knowing what
exactly we want out of it we don't know
what to study we don't know what type of
career we want and so many of us end up
studying and doing what other people
such as our parents want us to do
instead of what we want to do our entire
lives we are told that what matters most
is going to
cool so that we can find a good job so
that we can make lots of money and so on
but money in itself is not a goal it's
not a purpose sure we need money to
survive but money is not the end goal if
your primary goal in life is just to
make as much money as possible you can
never be happy or satisfied there is
always more money out there to be made
there is always someone richer than you
someone with an advantage that you don't
have that gives them the upper hand over
you and so on trying to make as much
money as possible just means that you
will work yourself too hard because
every moment that you are resting or
doing something else you will feel
guilty that you're not out there making
more money at that point money which can
be a blessing becomes a curse and an
addiction and eventually being obsessed
with making more money will have a
negative impact on our relationships and
on our physical health in the past most
people found their life's purpose in
religion religious teachings told us how
to live our lives if we want to be
rewarded in the afterlife
and the meaning of life was defined by
the values of our religion and while
many people are still religious today in
the modern world in which the focus is
on science and physical reality rather
than belief and metaphysics there are a
lot more people who no longer embrace
religion as their primary purpose in
life there are certainly many negatives
to embracing any doctrine religious or
otherwise without questioning or
thinking for yourself so the fact that
we no longer live in a world that is
controlled by strict religious
fundamentalism
is a good thing however there are also
negative consequences to having no
purpose at all and with the movement of
modern society away from relying
exclusively on religion for purpose and
meaning there is a danger that we will
be left without any purpose at all
wandering meaninglessly through life not
knowing who we want to be what we want
to do and what if anything we want to
achieve in Western liberal democratic
societies in particular there is a heavy
emphasis on individualism and everyone
doing whatever they want as long as they
don't violate the rights of others but
while this may work for people who are
decisive and know exactly what they want
in life there are many others who don't
know what they want to do in life or who
they want to be and this can create
serious problems for them
if you are pressured to go to school and
study and then find a job that makes you
lots of money but you have no idea what
you want to do and no guidance other
than you need to get a job and make
money chances are that you will feel
pressured to do something that you don't
want to do and you won't be happy even
if you do get a good job and make lots
of money you may be doing something that
you hate and if you can't cope with the
pressure to find that high paying job
you may withdraw from society altogether
becoming a permanent NEET or even a
hikikomori Japan obviously has an issue
with this type of strict social pressure
having a negative impact on some
segments of society but this pressure is
present in other nations as well and
this is where the Shonan protagonists
come in each and every one of us
regardless of what other people are
telling us or expecting from us needs to
stop and think what do we really want to
do in life what makes us happy what is
our purpose in this sense Shonen
protagonists are great role models
because they often have that clear
purpose sometimes it is an
unconventional purpose a purpose that
breaks the mold of society like for
example deque who wanting to be the
strongest hero even though he is quark
lists or hasta wanting to be the wizard
king even though he has no magic if
these guys were just listening to
everyone around them and following the
norms of their society they would have
given up on their dreams and gotten
regular jobs that might not make them
happy but would make them enough money
to lead a normal life and of course
eventually these two protagonists get
lucky thanks to plot convenience and dec
who inherits a quark that makes him
strong
while asta gets the ability to use ante
magic to nullify the magic of others but
while that is definitely plot
convenience the fact is that if deku and
asta had given up on their dreams after
realizing that they had no natural
abilities they never would have been in
the position to get lucky in the first
place
back when my brother goes in and I
started working on our YouTube channel
together I was in school studying a
completely unrelated field and I had no
knowledge of video editing or the
business aspect of YouTube if I just
stuck with what I knew and didn't go out
on a limb to try something new I never
would have become an anime youtuber in
the first place I certainly wouldn't
have become one if I'd listened to what
others thought and to the social
pressures of
around me because my parents and almost
everyone else I knew told me to focus on
getting a quote real job and stop
wasting time on YouTube of course at
some point we got lucky and the videos
we put out on our channel caught
traction and not everyone gets to that
point but if I had listened to the
social pressures and if I hadn't taken a
shot in the dark with YouTube I never
would have gotten to the point where I
could get lucky in the first place
just like dec who if he had given up on
his dream of being a hero when he found
out that he was quicklist never would
have had the opportunity to inherit one
for all and this is one of the big life
lessons that we can learn from shown and
protagonists think about what you would
want to do in life think about what you
consider to be fun and meaningful and
what would make you happy identify your
goal identify your purpose and then
pursue it pursue it even if it's an
unconventional goal even if the odds are
stacked against you and most people are
telling you to give it up if it's
something you love then the journey will
be fun
even without the destination and who
knows you might get lucky and find some
kind of powerup on the way that changes
your entire situation like Deku
inheriting one for all or a YouTube
channel getting a hit video that
suddenly helps the channel grow
exponentially anyway thank you all so
much for watching and feel free to give
me your feedback on this video in the
comments or on social media just hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
our anime poor patrons for supporting
this type of content including urbano
Tovar the one and only Gilgamesh and
originally if you'd like to support more
analytical and motivational content on
this channel consider becoming a patron
link in the description if you guys
enjoyed this type of video you can leave
a like to let me know I'll be happy to
make more in the future and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you